so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys i am thomas dopaziola
whatever you want to call me i am here
with marty o'neal what's up folks hello
story time orange super cool mighty
ducks
what do you call that it's not a jersey
sweating it's a jersey sweater jersey
sweater i like it
it looks super tight um guys
this episode oh sorry thank you by the
way i appreciate that no problem this is
the dopest usual podcast we're here to
talk about life drugs accomplishments
problems and everything in between that
was not an order guys we uh
are very happy to bring back this guest
the first time did not do it justice
this time she is back this is stoner
daddy rosie the person i live with my
roommate
that's what i'm going to start referring
to as my roommate my roommate got me
this sweet car bed for christmas
i sho we showed my brother uh grandma's
boy for the first time this week i've
never seen it
it's adam sandler movie right
uh well i think it's
a produce uh at adam sandler production
but he's not in it one thing i was sad
about uh-huh but yeah he's not he's not
in it once
that one has a stern word with him when
we get his ass in here oh one day
one day i'm gonna go like this a lot
i can't wait um so the first episode
let's just break this down rosie does
not like being on camera that much you
guys always ask new youtube videos she
doesn't really like it she doesn't like
it
so the first episode we did half solo
half rosie and we may or may have talked
about something but she got
age-restricted and demonetized and
blocked for our most wholesome episode
of the most wholesome we talked about
her church going grandparents
and god
basically basically just kicked the
video off the page essentially
so today we're not going to talk about
stuff
all right maybe we realize we don't need
a 45 minute intro no but remember what
we talked about we won't talk about it
that's probably why we had to move yes
sorry okay
that was a great episode it was a great
episode man it was going so good that
went age restricted demonetize oh
for wha oh
we'll talk about that with like
larry lawton next time
let's not talk about that on rosie's
episode so rosie's bag hi hi
hi what's up
nothing i am extremely burnt and waking
up right now you're supposed to go to
sleep
i was supposed to go to sleep today
but i didn't guys let's start this
uh let's start this episode off uh this
is not gonna be the regular episode
it's gonna be a little different
we're not married
yet but i'm gonna play the newlywed game
today
we've got some questions going on all
right we may have some things i may have
some conclusions to other stuff and
perspectives you guys want to see let's
go it's gonna be good i'm gonna try to
keep it really light for the first
couple minutes
and then we'll start living life i feel
like you're mom right now yeah but it's
different like so different ready
easy stuff easy stuff so you can see any
concert ever dead or alive who would it
be
concert band artist doesn't matter
well right now i would definitely want
to see david bowie
just because that's one person we've
been stuck on our whole entire
relationship
that would be really interesting i
didn't expect that david bowie and then
watching his music videos i could only
imagine what his show would be let's see
the old ones oh his old ones are my
favorite yeah they're really good mm-hmm
is it like i'm only choosing one that's
fine that's great that was fast
if you want to go for it mary j blind
uh i would love to see her yeah i'm not
a fan she's not a phone i love her such
a g answer yeah do you like concerts and
festivals and people like that uh not so
much festivals anymore kind of over it
unless like i have my own little area or
my own spot but concerts i'm totally
down for it yeah we used to go to so
many shows when we first started dating
like i feel like every other weekend we
were at a show
like hip-hop shows cause you were doing
like like rager show you were doing like
before you guys got together you were
doing like oh yeah i went to like crazy
shows i went to warehouse shows like
rock shows i've been to a few different
like
not crazy raves or anything like that
but raves too
but now
i don't know
for anything that's kind of about it
drink some dirty
dirty people unless i can get
individuals individuals
unless i can get like a really good seat
in a concert
then i'm down to go if not then i'm okay
i'll pass we got wean wien coming up
with my mom probably in colorado we got
tenacious d coming up
red chili peppers coming up you guys are
all over and we're gonna try to well we
already got tickets but i'm gonna try to
get myself a ticket
take your mom to go see lizzo
oh yeah yeah you don't my mom
likes that lady i'll show you yeah
so we'll see
so that's where you would go that's the
concert those are my two ready
if you could have any artist obviously
has to be alive okay if you could have
any artist ever actually play at our
wedding when we do it what a question
who would it be
i'm calling necro
i'm kidding my grandma go what what is
he talking about
it's called dead body disposal grandma
well i've always said step-by-step
process i've always said jay bug but i
know you're not a fan of jay bugs i
don't like reggae music no
okay the only person in life that
doesn't like it
i would love it she loves it i don't
know i don't know about you he's dope
for people that like that music i can
see why it appeals i just do not really
like that style of music april and all
her bridesmaids did the wobble all
choreographed what does that mean the
what the wobble yeah it's like a dance
it's like a fabulous dance from it was
like the lame with the rock yeah
yeah
like one of those type dances
choreographed
i could totally see april like uh
getting it oh my gosh look at this
hip-hop dancer yeah back in the day yeah
you can see i could see it happening i
need to go dancing with april now we
need to go out yeah
it's true
no dude um
come on come on i know i'm trying to
think
i don't know honestly are you serious
i know who you would want well we have
talked about one person too we just
recently that guy joji he would be
amazing to sing a few different songs
what do you mean that's different for
you
someone you want not something i already
said who i wanted jaybird that's it
oh i thought she'd just say mariah carey
okay
we can afford her hey fool
that's not what i asked
this is better we also can't bring david
bowie back to life i mean kevin you said
dead or alive that wasn't the question
mariah might show up like six hours late
though oh my god might be okay though
i'm gonna hire that
drag queen dude that looks just like her
do it
like yo
lip sync
lipstick for your life
come on i would not be mad i thought uh
rupaul drag race reference i got him
into it no no he looks identical he's
identical identical to her
if i showed you a picture of him you you
wouldn't know you wouldn't say which one
was which
mexican gay mixing guy yep okay i'm
beautiful
shocked me he's amazing i couldn't i had
mariah back on my wall back in fifth
grade and she had faith she's always
been she's a huge fan
don't care he does not care she's
amazing i wish i did i wish
i mean her voice is crazy
i don't like r b yeah at all
not even this much you never had a boys
to men around like oh no i like boys and
men i like their voices the music's cool
i don't i'm not ever gonna put r b on
yeah he's never going to go put a
voicemail like little anthony in the
imperial r and b old doo-wop r b
that's damn nearby
though i feel like that's one that's the
beginning of rhythm and blues
[Laughter]
yeah you're not putting on [ __ ] 112
and [ __ ] but he yelled in her ear and
peaches and cream video remember he gets
a side shot and it's her head he comes
up you go oh
he screams right in her ear bro i bring
this up a lot i know because when i do
play music at the house that song does
come on occasionally
and you pointed it out last time and now
every time i watch that music video he
screams he goes like that all i am
thinking about
one twelve one two oh joints oh we can
have giants 112 was a great band that i
don't know where they're at i was just
trying to think of people that i that we
could really get but of course mariah
carey would be more work harder and then
we'll get married
[Laughter]
let me get you some kettlebells some
ghetto ass uh spoken word poet that's
gonna be our writing
what if we can get steve buscemi to play
his character from wedding singer and he
can play 100 down
how about the wedding the dude that's
saying the wedding song during an old
school oh i i know uh uncle john he had
all their songs on the cd
group right it's like a group who does
stuff like a bunch of different movies
oh yeah that he he's saying candy shop
but like kind of like crooner
that was in there that was at the end of
hangover too
and then hey what's the same band that
they played in the hangovers the same
guys and everything
yeah my uncle john uh had all of it on
on dvd all right [ __ ] dvd burned cd
uh yeah i don't remember that one no he
i mean you play cds when you're around
yeah
mp3s i think oh i was showing off them
mp3s yeah new that new
um oh we're starting off very light okay
we're starting off lightly
no nothing bad i'm starting off lightly
ready next question
who's your who is the best character
from the office
best one i can have a top three or just
have to choose one who's made you laugh
more than anyone ever
off the top of my head i want to say
dwight
but it's just like a really hard
tie
between
creed and kevin
this [ __ ] wedding's off the wedding
is off
this is something
michael
michael scott is the funniest man on the
show i'm thinking of the whole entire
show as a whole the one person that's
there trips over to the last two seasons
he's not even there
he's still that funny okay i feel like
but it's okay it's okay who put who won
to the office or was it a mutual thing
no i walked into my apartment with
jeeves when we first got our apartment
he was watching on this i'm like what is
this the camera's shaky it's kind of
like documentary is it mockumentary i'm
like what is this reminding me rest
development style the way they film
i walked in and it was the episode where
jim wrapped dwight's desk like a present
make a present and then he sat down and
then he died laughing went no way
and like a month after that is when i
started having back problems so that's
how long ago it was yeah i remember the
day it happened but yeah that's how i
started watching the office and then i
started watching it my mom used to watch
it yeah i was i don't know i just
remember we started just watching it
together because i remember i had only
seen it from when jim and pam were
together i didn't see the other seasons
yeah i was late i started watching the
office the year and ended
yeah i never watched oh no yeah
never watched i was selling drugs yeah
then we started watching it together
yeah while i sold drugs
all right well you're allowed to have
your own opinion but some opinions are
wrong
i was just thinking of the entirety of a
show who's been there from the beginning
to the end i don't mean [ __ ] cause andy
bernard's up there and he started a
season tree yeah but i didn't i didn't
put him in my top three
that's crazy to me
dude when she where's sleep tonight i'm
gonna push her right out the bed
you better hope you dodged the signs in
the other room
that's fine with me
it's cold and everyone's bomb all right
we're doing all right all right we're
not doing anything stupid right along
here hanging out i don't even think
we've cussed on lunch yet [ __ ] adult
conversation here it's an adult
conversation that's true
um okay ready i got through some of
those first questions
on to another one and then i'm gonna get
into something i am excited about oh god
what was your first impression of
meeting my family
ready
rocco
can i tell the story of rocco yeah
the first time i ever met rocco
i don't know what we do
yeah remember
erica does the comments and helps us out
so he's gonna have to respond to all of
it love your child
um
the first time i ever met rocco i don't
know what we were doing i think we were
getting food or something like that i
just got off work
and then i just remember we were
somewhere and your mom called and she
was yelling
and she said you gotta go get your
brother blah blah blah and then so we go
to his little after school program and
i'm sitting in the impala
i think it was the impala the gold one
yep i'm sitting there and i just see
thomas walking and i see this little
mohawk kid
and he looks like he's just so upset
he's so
like defeated and he gets in the car and
thomas is doing shaking his head
the first time i ever met rocco we had
to go pick him up because he smacked
yeah because he smacked that little girl
from making fun of his mother he smacked
a girl across the top
in
line for lunch
you told my mom two days in a row about
this little girl messing with him she
just liked him or something yeah she was
just making sure she just kept going
hard on him bro and he didn't get it he
was he's a kindergartner guys oh in the
first grade first grade she was a little
bit he's a little boy he doesn't
understand yet so don't think rock both
wouldn't be no he was a little kid
little little child
i met him when he was turning six or
turning seven about to turn seven inside
but there was build up to it like yeah
he had been told by mom this girl will
leave me alone she's making fun of me
and then she sets up about his hair he
turned around he slapped her across the
face
and then every day i go i would go hey
remember when you hit that little girl
and i would say it i still do it i still
do it when you punch that girl in the
face it's probably one of my favorite
stories of rocco my favorite story of
all time he was so sweet did she stop
messing with him i have no idea never
asked never read a problem again yeah
she had problems again probably this
never said too so
she's got a 15 year old
dog
he's seven that was 17. he's barely 18.
that's that's a good one um here we go
my little brother hold on my little
brother okay what
one time
i had to pick up my brother
from school
and i had to find out what he did he is
this what
no same year same school i feel like
that's she i feel like that year while
he was there he got into a lot of little
issues
rocco really liked king of the hill as a
kid
my brother's very
i didn't expect that wild okay
he learns he learns from what he sees
so there is a scene
there's an episode where bobby hill
takes women's
self-defense classes
all right my brother remember seven
years old
he's watching king of the hill and he
sees bobby hill
taking women's self-defense and in the
episode it's great great episode
they teach you to hit him with the purse
kick him in the balls and say that's my
purse i don't know you
screaming as loud as you can
my little brother is in line at lunch
and this kid's [ __ ] with him
he turned around
and the teacher said she heard rocco
scream
that's my purse
i don't know you kicked the kid right in
the dick
and the [ __ ] kid dropped to the
ground had to go to the [ __ ] princess
bro he had to go to the [ __ ] nurse's
office because rocco hit him so hard and
then when i'm talking to the teacher
like he said he said
she said inside him like this oh my god
i want to throw up from laughter
but outside i go oh my god i'll talk to
my mom about this and i'm walking away
like
i'm just having this little ass head
and i were thinking
yeah yeah that's not your fault
probably should be watching the hill i
guess but king of the hill's the softest
show of all time and you learn
self-defense from it probably while your
mom didn't let him like watch american
dad and family guy that's not a true
statement he did all the time
he wasn't supposed to she didn't so hey
stopped sorry stop watching it no she
didn't do that she just let it be
she said hey don't watch it okay mom and
you she walks away and it's he's
watching it
there's no effort there
didn't beat his ass it used to be my
[ __ ] my little previous button on the
remote back
flip flop back all day until your show's
over tell your next you had the fancy
one i'd give you two channels back that
might [ __ ] you up though i never had
that much what
[Music]
you hit previous and it goes back and
forth between the two channels
you guys grew up with both parents
that's all i [ __ ] hear from this like
that's dual parent [ __ ] like two back
buttons oh my god
okay
my mom
i was scared of her at first
we were tripping balls right
no so the first first time i met her was
i think it was thanksgiving or christmas
when we went to your aunt pepper's house
yeah the first time she ever spoke to my
mom was the shroom night well i mean
i've met her first time she said oh
hello my name is and that was it yeah
like i met her before because she was
the cool scary
lady
but um
like actually like meeting her and
talking to her it was like a holiday
thing and i was just nervous because at
that time like
you and sharing weren't talking to her i
don't think so i hadn't talked to my mom
like three years already yeah both of
you guys weren't talking so it was just
super awkward like i'm just sitting here
like i'm your son's girlfriend hi
i've never had a girlfriend in my life
never once brought a girl home i had a
girlfriend in second grade
and that did not work
second grade obviously
sorry about that yeah so my mom was like
what the [ __ ] yeah she was just tripping
i was only nervous because like i've
heard crazy stories about her and then
but she's cool
that's fine
she didn't [ __ ] with you or give you any
[ __ ] or anything no what a [ __ ]
remember the water boy that's so cool
catches the ball and he runs and kicks
it drop kicks from the chest
that's what it did to my mom but in the
movie it was about talking about his mom
so i guess it's kind of the same
same sense no we've always been cool
yeah no one was always so cool mom's not
a [ __ ] i love her we talk like pretty
much on a daily basis yeah that was cool
all the time yeah
what was ella cool now she's older
chilling bro she's docile
we have a lot in common too we do we
have a lot in common
yeah okay next i could fight both of you
and win that's what this is
i'll fight but i might not win i don't
know we'll see
um okay
i think that's pretty good because we've
talked about a lot of my other family
members before
your dad's side it was super chill from
the beginning they were all super yeah
they're all chilling my family got it's
odd like my family got
chillin when i met rosie like before it
was just like oh god like i heard those
crazy stories about your grandpa and
then like he hugged me immediately and
everybody although my grandpa we talked
about last week yeah
he made it back
he made it back he is he's back home yep
that was funny knowing that watching the
episode back
yo the thumbnail you made for the clip
you
bastard
this man made it look like my grandpa
was gonna
slaughter a village
no he's just like looking all right oh
he's just the back of him looking like
he looks
listen he's in italy first of all you
got italy around the side
there's a plane off in the distance
flying away he's getting left he's got
his luggage if you i didn't notice it
like that i just saw like
oh i saw like the end of [ __ ] silence
of the lambs or whatever what's that one
where he's just walking in all white in
the other country
whatever that movie was signed to the
land or yeah hannibal
sorry grandma uh like two days before i
brought rosie over thanksgiving i went
to my grandma's
to talk to my grandma
about my grandpa you took me one day
after work it's right before
thanksgiving i don't remember what i'm
saying it's a couple days before
a couple days before i had to go oh yeah
you should grab my grandma's house
i tell my grandma like yo you talk to
grandpa
so i'm bringing my girlfriend over and
she's got hella tattoos and piercings
and [ __ ] and he says anything dumb i'm
gonna punch him
and i was like grandma
please
tell him because it's back when my
grandpa was still like a monster
but to my grandma i know and then
recently he's gotten all [ __ ] i can't
do anything so
it's it's that it's that what's going on
so i had to yeah he was cool he was cool
but i had to warn i had to he didn't
like tattoos
oh she was fully covered yet all my
piercings were hidden
still still i had to go make sure
i was like oh man all my uncles are
scared of my grandpa was like
i'll [ __ ]
powerbomb you through your table i
always feel bad i always feel bad for my
uncles and my dad they are deathly
afraid of my grandpa still mm-hmm
it's crazy grandpa walks in the room all
i'm just like these men are huge and
they're terrified of this i'm the
shortest person
i'm like all you can do is
yeah
and he's done but like six years ago i
get it yeah my grandpa's a lot of
properties about six years ago my
grandma told me the story she's like
yeah
yeah grandpa still got it
he was 82.
somebody was trying to go break into his
truck while he was working on his
apartments
and my grandpa pulled a machete out and
chased this man like three blocks marty
he could have chased him off
he wanted it
he chased him for blocks
he was home
the guy fell he was hoping for a
hamstring pull so he could go crazy on
this guy
that little trip
yeah he was waiting for the [ __ ] the
jason freddie versus jason tripp where
they just keep your grandpa was probably
one of the dudes in that [ __ ]
gladiator video we watched on wetube
oh no my grandpa's crazy as hell dude
was scary you would survive that yeah
yes for sure
that's some old school [ __ ] i just
remember my dad used to have an axe on
the car
in the car but under the seat he had a
[ __ ] axe hatch it or not
i don't know the difference how long
like
hatching that's it yeah and uh
you know what a shilling is yes
yeah yeah
one of those two because he had all his
gear with him
that just made me think of that that
just unlocked a [ __ ] memory
in the station wagon
in the station wagon
your friend
yeah
and i'm gonna pop up a [ __ ] picture
of a shillelagh there's some old-school
irish [ __ ]
it was from the motherland it's like oh
it's a mallet
it's just like a wooden mallet basically
that's scary
you know what's scary too
the indian fools or the aztec fools that
have that
stick and the rock on the thing and they
[ __ ] fling it and kill you have you
seen that i think about your grandpa
because he's like indian like that
yeah
wait he showed me some weapons like the
little asian girl and kill bill
yeah but the ball flies out like a like
a slingshot yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah i like you spin it but then you
hook it and it flings out dude i'll tell
that story i think i might have told it
but my grandma told me how he survived
when he was a kid this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
crazy i've heard it before it's wild we
should turn that into a story time
really wrap your mind around it
i understand why you're so mad at the
world and then go over like how he
helped everybody go back and forth
between the farms and stuff uh my
grandpa used to be a coyote too
he used to cut open his second because
diesel's have two tanks
so he would cut open his second tank
down the middle because there's two like
metal straps that go over it so he'd cut
it under that
a dude would go in it into a [ __ ] gas
tank from mexico
with just a coal in the back for [ __ ]
air
that's it
and he would smuggle fools in his
[ __ ] tank
as my grandma used to do goddamn bro
you have to be hurting to want to go you
know i go i got to leave
i'll get in this gas tank just wherever
i end up if i make it yeah like i'm
going to trust you
to unweld me
oh well there's
jesus christ
yeah my grandma told me about that my
dad told me about it too it's a trip
anyway
that's it you met my family
pretty much pretty good that was pretty
good okay let's get on to this get into
this are you ready what so guys
you've heard story times you've heard me
talk about a lot of things
one common factor from almost all the
story times is that you're there
um besides your high school christmas
i'm saying
so there's a different perspective on
all this [ __ ] okay
so last week we did
i talked about some [ __ ] like i said i
wouldn't think i didn't think i'd talk
about
but
also remember i took seven grams
and so did she
so this is a story time do you fully
remember that night not the first night
second night do you fully remember that
[ __ ] not
everything
what was going on on your trip i'm on
the bed ready okay i'm on the bed camera
moves
your dinner dialogue and now you go
okay
that was a good transition
no it's just you
solo shot
i wrote an entire music video today on
the drive to a meeting so sick
invoice for him
okay
from what i do remember
i feel like i just remember bits and
pieces of it but it's also because like
we always talk about that part
i remember
laying in bed and everything was dark
and then
do you remember how we had those windows
it wasn't a corner window but there was
a window right there in a window right
there i just remember seeing
everything spin
and then everything started spinning and
then i felt like
not that i was floating but it felt like
somebody was like picking me up like
just lifting me
and then
i remember meeting somebody
but i feel like i kept focusing on like
the window like everything kept spinning
but then like i said i remember meeting
somebody and talking
and it wasn't like
it wasn't like you were right there with
me but i knew you were there you know
what i mean like
like i always say like i can feel you
like you're right there like physically
or in the trip
so i remember okay
so when the window started spinning i
knew he was right here
yeah if when i think about it now like
the whole entire time you were sitting
right there next to me and it that's
kind of what made me feel okay
because a few other times when i did do
streams and i was like focused by myself
it was kind of bad i tripped out not bad
bad but it just made me feel weird where
i was like i'm kind of good
but this one i kind of just
let go i guess
i let go and it just felt like
i don't know
like i was floating
the void like thomas
kind of explained
or were you cruising over the
neighborhood and [ __ ] no i was just i
knew i was in my room
like that's where i was at
until like it made me feel like i was
focusing on the window so much it was
spinning and then i felt like i was
going towards the window and then that's
whenever i met
somebody or what you were talking about
when i met somebody and i knew you were
right there is whenever i floated
towards the window but not me it just
made me feel like my eyes were going
that way
like i knew i was in the bed the whole
entire time
my eyes were doing that too like it's
almost like camera control is like it's
like zooming in that's what it felt yeah
depth of field's changing
yes thank you
but that's how it made me feel like
like i knew i was still right there but
i was going this way
and then i remember
that part meeting meeting somebody
talking to somebody somebody was hugging
me and they were huge that's all i
remember i i was looking up the whole
entire time and when he would hug me it
was like i was buried in like that
person's body
but then
it was
i've never talked about this yeah i'll
never ask you i mean besides me and you
yeah i was like i've never talked about
this
i haven't even told like most of my
close friends besides monica
when you listen back to thomas's
explanation last episode did that like
um bring back memories oh yeah every
time he would talk about it i remember
what i saw
so like
after i met them and were talking
thomas was talking to them
i just remembered they were going
somewhere and i couldn't go and that was
it
i couldn't go with them did you have the
same sense that you were like from there
from that like board or whatever also
like
no i fell off or whatever no not at all
i didn't feel like that so that's why
when he talks about that it's kind of
like a trip because i didn't feel like
that i felt like i was meeting his
homies you were there with him yeah
the trippier layer of all this [ __ ] is
while i was editing this [ __ ] video
the
information we uncovered
what because as i was like listening to
you describe the red sundial oh the [ __ ]
you were texting yeah we looked it up
and it's like actual things that kind of
tie together to what was it i don't i i
remember reading going what the [ __ ]
because it i mean the way you described
it i looked it up and then you know i
found like an article this is like i
don't want to butcher it we can put i'll
put it up on the screen this is like the
aztec sun god that they worshipped he
was a leader of all warriors
and that that made sense to me because
it was like it related to the warriors
on this on the sh on the board and it
related to the light that you fell into
and from
him being the sun god i mean it's what
it showed you
that that red pendant was like an
artifact that's exactly what it looked
like though that's why what you text me
is i mean that's exactly what the [ __ ]
is yeah like
dead dead on same color [ __ ] texture
so to me it's like the mushroom showed
you that
almost like your baby was like
introducing itself and then the warriors
the leader leader of the you know
warriors this aztec god was referred to
as
so i mean that that's just too
undeniable not to mention that it's some
crazy [ __ ] yeah
it's [ __ ] weird
so then it's like rosie kind of tapped
into that and then she's like oh it felt
like i was just kind of meeting your
boys like this isn't where i'm from
that's like where you know like you
brought me here that's what it felt like
like i was just with him meeting his new
friends and that's crazy because that's
it i mean that's you guys like sinking
out
yeah i don't know it was a
it was definitely [ __ ] weird and when
we watched it back on monday i was just
really going over it and thinking about
it like how [ __ ] intense it really
was
like it was insane how wild it was but
then after that happened like i said
i felt like they were leaving and i
couldn't go
so whenever that happened it made me
feel like i went back into the bed
and then
yeah he was just how he said he fell
it just made me feel like i just laid
back down
and then after that i just kept focusing
on outside and everything was spinning
around me
i
i don't that's what i'm saying like i
don't remember everything just the whole
spinning thing and then me and you
coming out of it
because you kept saying like you didn't
want to
see it anymore or something like that i
can't remember honestly i mean it was
pitch black it was hard to well you
described going and seeing horrible [ __ ]
too yes it was [ __ ] crazy she doesn't
remember any of that i don't remember
seeing none of i asked her the net the
next morning and everything she remember
[ __ ]
i remember all that [ __ ] it might have
like hit her way harder because she's
smaller than you so like maybe it was
like an overwhelming amount at seven
grams
it just made me feel like i was floating
in our room the whole entire time until
he told me he didn't want to see it no
more
and then it made me feel like oh [ __ ] i
need to make sure he's okay and i just
kept trying to snap out of it remember
the bed being broken in the middle
okay i wanted to bring that up but okay
we thought the bed was broken in the
middle i swear we're laying on it we
were like remember like this it's like
we were in and i could have swore the
bed had broke and it was like this and
you're both on one side no we're both in
the middle laying next to each other
talking and i'm like rosie did we break
our brand new [ __ ] bed oh my god and
it was the most expensive thing we've
ever bought at the time it was like
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] much i was like
i thought the bed was broken like this
and we were both walking and seeing the
same [ __ ] the morning after we [ __ ]
ate and got out from the living room
went in with the bed's not broken that's
fine
[ __ ]
that's all i remember i just i
confronted him by that detail that's one
thing we talked about like an hour like
why is the bed broken remember that [ __ ]
she was like damn like no no it's like a
wall
it's like broken i saw it i saw the bed
i know what i saw
i know it was [ __ ] broken because we
it was a trick
i had to roll weird to get out of the
bed but maybe it was just both of them
sheets all piled up maybe you were
seeing no the bad bed was marty if i
buffalo bills this table in half and i'm
laying on my back with it broken that's
what the [ __ ] bed looked like okay
it's not closed but it's like oh [ __ ] i
broke this table
that's what i thought
yeah i was like how do we break the
[ __ ] bed and then we're just thinking
that's okay we'll just we'll not have a
box spring yeah [ __ ]
and then i'm thinking how did it get so
deep
and then yeah in the morning i remember
having to like i swear to god i had to
like roll weird and shift out because it
was so high up on the sides see that's
one thing i forgot to mention yeah i
could have swore broke the bed uh did
not
and then we were thinking how the [ __ ]
did this bed break we're just laying
here and then like was it when we landed
did i snap her in bed yeah and then i'm
thinking of all these things like i
didn't even think about that because i
felt like i dropped in the bed too so oh
my god yeah that's what i was thinking
i thought it was weird
that's something i forgot to mention i
completely forgot to mention that about
that until you started talking about
your emotional trip and then i was
thinking
that's crazy
yeah that's fine
it's fine okay bed's fine so is that
everything you remember
yeah
and then it was like the next day
i remember we streamed again right
oh no the second night is the night
you're talking about the first night
was like really soft yeah because it
wasn't intense but we ate the same
amount the first night we tried watching
that movie what to call it always for it
thank you the wall
we tried watching it and then always
once and gets to one certain part we
have to stop it because you can't deal
with it
and i've never watched it on mushrooms
before so it's the worst
it's so crazy because right when i'm
getting into it he's like no i'm like
okay i know how this makes you fail it's
not fair so yeah you got it
all right yeah no we gotta bail out at a
certain point yeah the hospital scene i
just have to leave i just remember too
that was the first time i ever saw like
i guess visuals because remember
martin's homie
his beard
he thought i was laughing at him but i
wasn't laughing at him harris that i
kind of was left he's a lawyer now yeah
he's a lawyer
so
i don't know why we took shrooms while
everybody was there at first that was at
the push this at the posterior's house
this is before no not the push tree's
house it's the other house
was it yeah i thought it was outside
where the little bench was at the tree
size with the light in the back with the
treadmill this was the other house and
everybody was sitting on the table i
remember the beard part but i'm
imagining it in the push street okay
remember our kitchen it was like the big
huge island and then that weird bar
where you put your tv on and then we had
a table and they were sitting at the
table and me and you were by the bar
thing and then that's when his beard
started growing and his eyebrows started
going crazy and i just could not stop
laughing at him i felt so bad
yeah i felt so so bad because i he
thought i was laughing at him but he his
beard was like like eddie murphy like
like doing that to me oh uh clumps yes
that's what he was doing like going
crazy
and i could not stop laughing at him and
he has a big ass beard too yeah
that must have been another time we
tripped though because
i would never allow that many people at
the house i've eaten that much mushrooms
yeah i didn't remember why i'd do it in
a different time because we had that bag
of mushrooms we were eating for a long
time and then we did seven and then we
did seven again and then i went and then
i got so scared i had about three zips
left in this huge jar we brought to l.a
and then i thought for some reason oh my
god i forgot that i got a weird-ass
feeling about some
uh let's just skip that part i got this
weird feeling about some [ __ ] that was
gonna happen
and i threw away all the drugs i had
and i threw that whole jar in the
dumpster
and i went
i'm not giving these to anybody they're
two years old also
oh yeah i don't want that experience i'm
not ready
i was scared to take those muscles i was
so scared
they were this long it was
i've done yeah a couple other times and
i've never had an experience where it
like intertwined with somebody else
yeah that's what tricked me out the most
and it made me nervous like if we did it
for another night again
something crazy is gonna happen yeah
i didn't like that so that's what i said
i stopped for [ __ ] [ __ ] here i had
them for so long like these are special
and then it got so late i'm like you
know what some [ __ ] i'm like i'm
throwing these in the [ __ ] trash
yeah so that was it the end of that so
that's all you remember that's all i
remember
all right on to the next part
you ready yeah i'm ready are you ready
i'm nervous we're at 42 minutes in
having a clock
it's insane
having a clock is crazy all right this
is awesome
here you go
there you go so
here we go we are not married we're
gonna play the [ __ ] newlywed
game marty feel free to chime in if
you've got any questions you got any
things you want to ask
all right i know you i know you know all
right this is going to be called
do you know a [ __ ]
question mark
there that's normally called how well do
you know a [ __ ]
roommate quiz wait
do you have to answer these questions
about me too yeah same time
same time
also
real quick before we even start yes
marty
i found a story time orange rolex oh
gosh and i think i am going to go buy it
please
it is [ __ ]
insane oh [ __ ] insane
that one's hard i like rosie it's the
same exact one as yours oh yeah except
that hers is a little darker i haven't
even gotten a good look at it yeah it's
the purse is a little darker it's it's
awesome it's it yours is the light one
here's the dark one
that shouldn't be looking crazy on the
side it would look so
nice orange i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna get a shoelace and then i'm gonna
wear on my as a necklace
what
take a little
versace
[Laughter]
um
yeah i found a couple today
pretty nice a couple i found a couple
different variations of orange i'm sure
and there's ones like why is it 10 times
expensive oh god no it's beautiful it's
[ __ ] insane but we'll see
we will see the outside looks like some
soulja boy diamonds
it's got diamonds around the bezel thing
but they're like rainbow colored
oh [ __ ] but with the orange oh my god
it's so stupid looking i love it
i love it so much are you ready i'm
ready are you ready
this is what he called do you know
[ __ ] and here we go question
number one
i know this answer that's nothing do you
know this answer i know this isn't
wait you should have came up with a
question it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter this is not fair but i know
you'll know it [ __ ] this is not the
reason
this is an interrogation
are you ready yeah once you're together
[ __ ]
what was the first movie we ever saw
together
anchorman 2
what wasn't it
oh it was about the bird but i think i'm
trying to puke why because you're wrong
i am wrong oh my god
i don't remember oh you're going to feel
so played and ridiculous when i tell you
what
movie we ever watched together anchorman
2 came out like four years ago
no it did not i don't know
i don't remember kind of feel so dumb
right now i'm trying to think the first
movie we ever watched i don't even think
we were dating yet no we weren't because
i think we went with monica we did and
it was the movie theater by the mall
and what else
[ __ ] i spoke i snuck a fifth of jack
daniels
and neither got [ __ ] [ __ ] up in the
movie
[ __ ] face
so [ __ ] drunk it was kind of dumb i
used to do it all the time
serious
i can like see us going to the movies i
don't remember 2009
had to be like 2011
2010 2011.
my memory
hey i was halfway there you're right
i can't you're getting a second i can't
one guy plays everybody
thank you
i'm gonna have you drop kicker
jack and jill [ __ ] oh my god oh
my god how did you forget
yeah look at that face
face if you know you [ __ ] up
well you said plays everybody and i just
thought of eddie murphy all over again
of course but who else plays as a person
other than themselves [ __ ] himself
place his own sister oh that was the
first movie i'm going to when you're
asleep it's okay
right off the bat
hey i was like halfway there i
remembered everything else that's true
you did remember everything else
ironically it means april's first movie
we ever watched together
you say email final destination oh my
god stop that
what are the odds like the irony
[Laughter]
number one
i think so i don't know i was uh
seven
couldn't have been numbered
imagine the storyboard um
oh god
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
well you're [ __ ] batting oh for
nothing right i got half of it i hit it
hey
hey here you go i got first base that's
fine nope don't count
we didn't have jen i just got got april
contact high we had an awkward ass first
because i think we went over it
i took a hit and i put my sweater over
her face
[Laughter]
will you want to have a baby right now
that was 15 years ago here we are
oh my god
we got drunk off gin or we didn't have
gin but i cut her contact high and had
awkward kiss
he watched final destination and three
and it worked it was our final
destination oh [ __ ] that's true
good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
i think i i tell marty good [ __ ] at
least like four times an episode that
was great little puns and dads great the
dad joe king over here oh no me and
emily were talking about like marty's
quick yeah he's really oh you mean like
a rapper
wordplay master
this one is this one is we should have
marty do the questions we should have
you should have um ready question number
two
what was my first job what was your
first job
you didn't moving
or like actual job
i mean yeah you could say that i guess
ted you worked at dole
that's not true no not dole what was it
it's over there
i'm looking terrible right now
i'm getting real bad right now
you were at the uh you had the job over
there by the thing you got paid you paid
my first job was building a fence for my
dad and my grandpa
i'm just kidding he was moving it was
moving yeah you're right slash
housekeeping in chat right yeah pretty
much my first job child labor child
labor
that's cool that blew my mind when you
told me they had you doing laundry and
[ __ ] whoo
the people you were moving no it's not
that okay yes that's we had to finish
some laundry before
[ __ ] people
you had to do people's laundry
yes
could you imagine and then drain the
water you got movers coming and you just
asked start it while we're moving other
stuff
that's disgusting
who does that dirty some dirty dishes
oh yeah you imagine i've packed people's
entire rooms
you want people going through your room
the [ __ ]
thanks
um
so yeah you got it right your first job
first job ever that you actually got
paid for that wasn't the church
cleaning atvs
and dirt bikes
oh [ __ ] this is pretty lame that's
[ __ ] awesome what are you talking
about you sit outside all day i know but
you get to clean cool stuff it's better
than [ __ ]
working at mcdonald's doll sucks my dad
wouldn't let me work fast food i tried
to work fast food all the time so he
would not let me work that's a good dad
well you're just like no you're not he's
there go cleaning trying to give him
credit yeah
it was across the street now
that was the best part and wendy's and
wendy's
guys i've changed the [ __ ] rv tire
this week you did it
you did yes we run into trailer i need
the button to go camping thank you yeah
thank you because i did not think i was
capable of that [ __ ] you put it on a
jack
yeah man we had to get creative the
trailer the tire shredded okay
the one tire is 12 years old all the
other tires are totally yeah yeah so you
gotta like
jack this [ __ ] thing up with these
little crates so you get it up on one
side and then you gotta he man the
[ __ ] tire off yeah yeah so it was it
was creative change almost ruined the
trip but it gave me the chance it was on
the way man
right when we were getting there
yeah
the [ __ ] bust like 10 minutes out from
the campsite
we're only 10 minutes away
because normally you got to rely on a
real adult like i'm going to be honest
the dude next to you is the real adult
the dude the campsite next to you the 50
year old white dude he knows how to
change the [ __ ] tire yeah and there's
one you know like it's inevitable
but uh i'm not a real adult
i've got three kids i'm getting there
next time be like any yeah
yep i know yeah i felt like more of a
dad yeah
so anyway i just want to throw that out
there
that was the most random [ __ ] ever we
talked about and then your first job i
moved to [ __ ] i changed a tire this week
you said atvs and whatever that made me
think of it i had to bring that up i
heard letters
and motor vehicles so my mind i don't
know the difference atv no they're not
even close the [ __ ]
that's scary i would have been like you
know it's trips over [ __ ] this clearly
i'm pushing this thing off the [ __ ]
cliff yeah yeah let's get the [ __ ] out
of me
so
that's cool oh and that was your first
job
good you got it right are you ready
are you ready
question number three yes
these aren't fairy who is the most tidy
dirty ass fools is what i wrote
this this this this answer can fluctuate
what do you mean who is the most hiding
out of you or me oh you are okay i have
been lately
but you want to say fluctuating yeah she
has been i have been very on point
lately
but you're so busy that is just too
chaotic and i feel like the reason why
any time tom is like we're going to
clean today i'm like no we're not
because do you know what you have to do
today
you guys need to get her cleaner i know
but it just makes me feel weird having
someone in my house cleaning my [ __ ]
yeah we got this team of ladies comes
through
45 minutes it's like sanitized it looks
like you hit the house with a [ __ ]
photoshop filter it's like does it look
like after taz cleans up yes
it smells like lemony fresh it's amazing
yeah i need a [ __ ] clean my
house i am [ __ ] behind
we wrote everything out the other day i
need about seven more hours a day to
accomplish the things that i
accomplished
that's not real
how the [ __ ] are we doing all of it i
don't know how you're getting this we're
getting her we're getting there but [ __ ]
anyway yeah most tidy when i met rosie i
cleaned her her room
because rosie's a girl that goes hey
she's kelly kapoor so i have this new
method i throw all my clothes in the
middle of the room and i walk around a
pile picking outfits that's her that is
i walked the win and went
this is the water that you served
looked around like i mean you can walk
around my room and mostly all the
clothes are clean because i just didn't
know what i wanted to wear yeah i mean
it looks like someone gets raided i
still do that but now i put my phone
back her house her room was [ __ ] and i
remember like yo let me work
i'm all [ __ ] dying let me organize
this room
and i organized the [ __ ] out of it and
it was quite baller and the stain in the
middle of her room was from me
the one used to be anthony's house it
was
um
but now yeah it's rosie for sure when
you guys get your baller ass house
though you'll have your little changing
room with the island baller house house
oh i'm gonna have to have people home oh
i'm gonna make
um
i'm gonna make trent put holes in my
walls
that are like display cases and i'm
gonna set up my toys and cool [ __ ] in
different parts of the house and you
walk in and go terminator one weird
why is it right here
[ __ ] isn't it yeah and that's it
i used to put strings from the
apartments from the upstairs neighbors
[ __ ] thing fishing line all the way
down to the bushes by mine and i would
get a pen cap shove it in a gi joe's
hand the one that does this and it fits
perfect you can hook the little pen cap
lip on the string with the [ __ ] gun
and you can zip line those [ __ ]
down wait till i get my [ __ ]
you ever seen blank check exactly you
ever seen richie rich thank you that's
what's going to happen instead i'm going
to be like just a cloud of smoke
the whole time
yo the first thing i'm going to do when
you get a house is i'm going to throw a
[ __ ] bottle on the ground because i'm
going to be so happy
a bottle of liquor okay just don't
outside okay
i was like don't decide i'm gonna step
on that [ __ ] in two weeks okay
i'm gonna be so happy we'll punch a hole
in the wall and like trent
make it right there
that's where i want the first [ __ ]
toy section it's gonna be very cool i'm
gonna press a light all my toy [ __ ]
lights up not even toys just fun stuff
collector shirt my vhs of the mask
[ __ ] like that
you right now like yo make your house
whatever you want that's what it's gonna
look like pretty much what would rosie's
house look like like mine it's like his
okay yeah i should have known that i
have like certain things
except she does like more stuff like
this
more a little more chaotic i like apple
store [ __ ]
i want to walk in and go there's one
thing on my table yeah i don't mind
that one like right now in my house i'm
trying to keep a nice book a different
book
a franklin's book
i have some you know different art books
and i got you know a vape pen
i'm nice i've been keeping it clean
i haven't let my [ __ ] clothes hit the
ground
[Music]
i'm mm-hmm good
i'm trying because we'll be like yo
you want you want to go to sleep early
tonight like cool 17 days later we go
that
oh [ __ ] we tried we really did try but
we're busy as [ __ ]
so tidiness i almost just say tie
whoever's not busy basically because i
[ __ ] work a nice dog [ __ ] out of our
back room this weekend oh yeah you did
it's like a walk-in closet with a bed in
it as long as somebody's being tidy
though we both hate it being dirty yeah
i can't think yeah i don't know if
that's like a [ __ ]
a dumb thing in people's brains but i
cannot do the same [ __ ] if my one thing
when you have kids it's just their
mission to just like [ __ ] your [ __ ]
every two to three hours just [ __ ] it up
for you so you get to clean it and just
reorganize it and then they come back
three two three hours just [ __ ] it up
for you
yo your nail looks crazy broken i know
it looks so good she snapped her shirt
at the gym um sorry it looks great we're
in a podcast i'm gonna talk like we're
on facetime sorry sorry sorry sorry all
right next one no where's april
ready ready
question number four
how many kids do you want and how many
kids do you think i want and i gotta
guess yours yeah you can't do this i
can't ask the question
that's like hey pick a number between
one through ten what am i thinking
that's what i just did with this i'm
sorry guys i'm [ __ ] burning high
i just watched newlywed outtakes when
they say funny dirty stuff in the 70s
so i've never really watched a newlywed
game i just watched the funny outtakes i
know it's probably kind of boring then
oh for sure
and you can't know the answer that's why
you're supposed to have a notebook and
go oh that's why i said we should have
got white board i'm sorry give me that
other lighter please
we'll do that at another time okay
as [ __ ] every time
we get a wrong question
make a wheel
yeah make a wheel april has to come
through that will be like yeah april's
gonna come too together
like king's cup remember all the cubs
and at the end you gotta chug the full
couple liquor
i got it once i got it i threw up at a
party
i felt stupid
that sounds amazing
i knew it was gonna be me it was taka
taka oh i played where everybody was
mixing some people had beer
and taco
beer
liquor oh god it was disgusting
you ready okay next you said kids kids i
would say two max me
what i want and then i have to add say
what you want i'll [ __ ] this
game
jesus christ i need a rewind button
yeah
i must drink you about 16 dr peppers
that's how many kids i want i want one
athletic
shrimp boat captain vietnam fan
daughter
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] all right uh i think you want
two
that's what i think yeah yeah that's
what i think you would yes that's it
that's it yep that way they have a homie
hope they're not dicks back to back god
no about lethal weapons yeah i was like
give me a couple years in between if you
want them to be friends you gotta it's
gotta be pretty [ __ ] close me and my
sister are four years apart we're
probably gonna have twins though marty
no oh gosh i know so we'll probably end
up having three kids uh-huh yep we're
gonna have twins for sure a few sets
please don't say that
i ain't even tripping it's kind of cool
you get a twofer you get it out of the
way i mean that's how i feel about it
it's not horrible
yeah
boom done it's a whole year of your life
yeah it is
more yeah
it takes almost like a year to bounce
back it's two years
guess we'll see i don't know we'll see
yeah my grandpa's a twin
it skipped my
it's coming for me
oh i know it
who else who else is my family
there was somebody else
on your dad's side somebody else is a
twin too yeah i can't remember i can't
remember on my dad's side you've been
calling it for a while i've been saying
my aunt twins already know that i've
been saying it too yeah i feel it i know
i'm just doing it
i hope they're not boy and girl twins
because i made a boy and girl twin in la
when they said that i broke the tree
branch and then i got in trouble
[ __ ] those
kids my mom's watching this you remember
that [ __ ] you even believe me he didn't
believe me or sharing you [ __ ]
i know what time bobby's world comes on
i said i was inside at 2 30 they said it
happened at 3. bobby's world starts at 2
30. this is simple evidence
simple [ __ ] evidence and nobody
believed me and i went but guys
if it starts and i explain it they go
pull up tv guide i didn't remember
thinking like are you guys [ __ ]
stupid i'm five
and i just explained this
you we don't give a [ __ ] we just want to
have you in trouble yeah i was pissed i
was upset
that was pretty much it sorry i don't
why did i bring that up oh my kids
that's [ __ ] downstairs [ __ ] them how
are you man dog come on the [ __ ]
pocket no
he's gonna be all like there's smoke in
here
there was ashes in here at one point
nah he'd be [ __ ] awesome i'm just
kidding i saw how mandela merced one
time with my mom
we were driving getting onto the freeway
uh and i watched bobby world's real
heavy
and we're getting onto the freeway right
by merced right by in merced right by
the mcdonald's on our street going
toward the south
and we get on and we get behind it it
says mandel one and my mom goes mandel
one it's like 1994. five maybe i'm like
that
and we drive by and it's some [ __ ]
dude with curly ass jerry crow and
uncles oh my god i'm a mandal
and i'm like what do you think bobby's
world the guy that comes on and go
i saw bobby and i remember i told
everybody at school i saw bobby's world
this [ __ ] oh my god i was like a
little kid i was like five years old but
it was awesome
it was crazy you know how he met now so
maybe he'll remember he's out there
reenacting
i'll bring it that's the icebreaker do
you remember this one remember one time
you were driving
like yeah you with your mom right by
mcdonald's
you inspired me that's what he's gonna
say
yeah how many will be great on the show
[Music]
hey what's up guys just taking a moment
to talk about one of our sponsors and
this is manscaped and right now if you
go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's going to give you 20 off your
entire order plus free shipping guys
it's june and with father's day right
around the corner manscape is bringing
something back the performance package
4.0 this comes with a weed whacker nose
hair trimmer crop preserver all
deodorant ball toner boxer briefs and a
travel bag does your dad shave his balls
with the same trimmer that he shaves his
face with if so gross also if so shame
on you if you watch the show and you
know your dad does that [ __ ]
weird also stop being cheap and get him
some manscape and with a performance
package those briefs are moisture
wicking performance that means you're
not going to be dripping sweat off your
balls so remember go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola is
20 off of anything you buy this month or
anytime plus free shipping remember
don't be a cheapskate get your dad some
stuff to trim his dick up
hey guys thank you so much to manske for
being a long time sponsor and thank you
guys for supporting the brands that
support us back to the episode
number five
finish the sentence
because
oh what that's it finish the sentence
because
because what because
because i said so
oh rosie rosie her memory
dog are you talking about that
would you understand that yeah i would
it's a good answer to me no that's not
fair i would have had any questions
because i love you
you [ __ ] jerk
because we used to say it all the time
and write it down
because i love you
no i do because i still do that but i
had no idea where we were going with
that that's why i was like
do this still
oh the thing i do i didn't know that you
meant the thing i do
i'm gonna scoop these ashes real quick
close close your eyes but open your
mouth
i'm gonna [ __ ] get you that's not
fair that's the new tar and feather
yeah that's not fair though i was saying
nothing i couldn't
because because what i said finish this
no but you were so confident you're like
i'm gonna loft this alley-oop
i'm so sorry it's okay
it's okay
dude i can't wait i'm later on i can't
like i'm gonna sleep on both sides of
the bed by myself it's [ __ ] insane
i'm like yo how is it down there and i'm
gonna be like oh my back is so much
better let's just sleep in the other
room i'm gonna put that mattress on top
of my mattress
is different size i don't give a [ __ ]
would you be [ __ ]
you losing right now rosie you this it's
not there do you have one
not that easy then
it's hard because you know the person so
well
i thought shut up
i picked some weird ass [ __ ] i just
picked wild weird dumb [ __ ]
do you know
my phone number do you know where we
live
you know how old i am
marty
uh no
that's marty
i was letting you know that that's his
name
you get an og treatment right now i'm
gonna just keep it going
all right ready i need my glasses it's
all right it's all right that was it for
newlywed game
[ __ ]
we're gonna change this to do we just
meet that's the name
did we just me
is this a speed date that's what i'm
gonna call this this was speed dating
with two people that know each other
you
[ __ ] not not how we anticipated this
girl i'm a [ __ ] cute right now
you ready
i'm done [ __ ] with you
story story time back to it just like i
said earlier i need your perspective
this one time
this one time i got pulled over
with like like two felonies
in the car
the amount of wax was definitely a
felony the car or the amount of carts
are definitely a felony the weed not so
much
but remember
one time
that we were pulled over while you were
hitting a vape pen
can you finish
the rest of that
do you remember the story or no
of course i remember stories do you want
me to tell it and then you chat and then
you tell your perspective on it
i think we talked about this before on
here pretty positive maybe season one
not my finest moments that's all i could
say one time
i was selling drugs
and i had a lot of it
and i had so many slabs slabs like hash
sorry [ __ ] snobs bho shatter i mean
like i had like a half pee
so i had quite a bit of slabs i had like
pizza box like three slabs of a pizza
box right right yeah it was a lot
um but i had like 200 different kind of
cards
and like
nah like eight pounds but a fire
so like when a cop sees that we think oh
i need to bust this [ __ ] let's
look great for the paper like it
was purple shining through the back like
he looked cool
and one thing about me is i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] but i'm also
very polite
so i don't put anything in the trunk
i'm going to merced i'm in merced
i'm going to [ __ ] set towns around
right there bakersfield l.a
it's hot
oh i was about to say we had to keep it
in the car right kept in the cars was
too hot and those packs get they lose
weight all right they lose [ __ ]
weight in the heat i don't care what
anybody says they lose [ __ ] weight it
like dries it out or something and loses
moisture
i i swear to god i've been [ __ ] i'm
like i waited at his house i know it was
on point i get here and i have to
[ __ ] reimburse him for six grams [ __ ]
like it's
i know it loses weight in the heat over
the time maybe i'm a wrong scientist
um
so we're driving she's next to me
we're just driving i space out and i'm
driving over the speed limit
chp i don't see him in time rosie's
hitting a vaporizer like a vape pen uh
like uh you know
just a lip pen it was a long time ago so
she's hitting the pin
blowing clouds
no we were smoking a joint
we were smoking a joint
that's what it was sorry sorry this
we've been pulled over like five times
like this no three times
so we were smoking a joint and i saw him
boom and as soon as i did i went
knock the cherry off into the into the
ashtray
rolled the windows down let it start
going just let it go go let it go let it
go because i knew he was coming as soon
as the cherry hit the [ __ ] ashtray
and then closed it
i saw him coming out like oh [ __ ]
the only thing i always think of i don't
care about the giants think of
my license [ __ ]
like i can't drive with in a piece i
can't drive and go i'm fine that scares
me yeah so
i see him coming i'm like [ __ ]
rosie hit that pen as hard as you can
i'm gonna rip that pen rip that pan
right
okay just just so he's like oh it smells
like
okay she had a vape pen at most
but like we weren't smoking it right now
you know i said there's no smoke
detected they can't prove it excuse
every time yeah prove it but yeah i have
a vape head in here man i'll have weed
in here and when we went on tribes i
always had about two yeah we just kept
them they were just
for the fake out
obviously you know what weed smells like
versus a vape but you can't say [ __ ]
the [ __ ] you gonna say
and uh he pulls us over
and rosie
while we were getting pulled over dude
while we were getting pulled over
as we're getting pulled over
she's hitting the joint right when i see
him i go [ __ ] up
she's smoking a joint recording herself
like a video
she's smoking i didn't see it she didn't
see him because she's just watching
herself why would she see him she's not
driving why she can pay attention i was
spacing out and i went oh [ __ ] 84.
i saw him with
[ __ ] and i knew he was coming because i
was in the lead of all these cars
and rosie just drops her phone
immediately puts it down and starts
[ __ ] uh getting the vape pen out
starts hitting it i'm airing it out
cop pulls over i gotta pull this over
and then he comes to my window and he
comes to rosie he comes with my window
and he says
to you that you're speeding i'm like
yeah i'm sorry it's spacing out and then
he was like well it kind of smells in
here and i was like oh we're hitting the
vape we said we have a vape but we're
smoking it now basically we're like not
smoking now like smelling here for some
reason my phone was like perfectly up
and the video was just going looping of
me smoking
looping
on her
i was quick
and said oh no it's my vape pen it
lights red on the bottom and it actually
did
what he did was like so you guys aren't
smoking in here what about that video
playing on your lap that's what he said
i went oh yeah that's exactly what he
said rose i went no [ __ ] way is this
happening and she went huh clicked it
off
closed it because you can't open it
without a lock and she goes no that was
a vape pen the red light see red light
on the bottom
and he just
how much weed you got on your man like
my legal limit because
all right legal limit huh
no
i was like well she has a half pound i
have a half pound with the limit we're
fine we're fine i say sure i need to
check i'm like i mean that's legal
you know all right i'll be right back
with your ticket oh shut the [ __ ] up
one peak
one
and it's over
that's all you had to do was do me a
favor
go like that with in the bag that's all
he had to ask for like i was done
as this is before no smell matters
this is a long time ago so this back
when smell was probably caused still and
he was the way i played it off i think
like nah like
now it's legal
all right man let me know and i was
inside him like that no i was like [ __ ]
it's over [ __ ] i'm going to chat and i
was like i said i was like oh the dui
the license is what i care about
but that's the time rosie almost [ __ ]
played me
without even trying without even dry i
couldn't believe it she i go cop she
goes oh
she's putting it away and then just it
just happened to stay on
and it was just her
smoking a badass [ __ ] joint with the
clothes she's wearing in the same car
like obviously
you can't deny it not my finest moment
yeah not not at all it was pretty
but i dropped my phone and like what are
the odds that it just stayed right there
i couldn't going up
on a loop
i couldn't believe it
i mean it worked out jesus christ
it worked out yes but for everyone out
there that's heard that story that's the
other side of it that's there's no other
side it's it's kind of hard because my
side is your side we were right next to
each other yeah there's not much
difference between while i was looking
at him
and then this happened you know what i
mean but i just wanted to know what was
your perspective on mushroom trip what
was your perspective on this and then
ready
one more all right let me give one more
idea ready for this it's a two-parter
story time
your perspective
i have done this story time called strip
clubs
i've done story time called strip clubs
and in it i talked about a certain strip
club please do not say the name
where you and i went you're so far from
the mic oh move it towards you there you
go
um
we went to a certain strip club in l.a
we'll not say
i mean we were just going to have a
chill like a just hang out okay
and what happened in that place
do you remember when i was first one
the one i'm talking about
yes
the chicken wings
oh hell no i'm talking about the scary
one oh the scary one oh by ourselves by
ourselves
yes
so
i'll set it up
meanwhile you're going to do a strip
club
we drive because i'm like i'm not going
to really drink and they don't even
serve alcohol
so i drive the car
we didn't get an uber
no nope
i drive there we walk in i'm like oh
this is cool
we're at the strip club walking around
it's not a very big place i'm like oh
this is kind of cool i guess no alcohol
damn it sucks
all right [ __ ] it we're hanging out for
like
45 minutes maybe yeah let's just say
maybe an hour maybe
and me and rosie are there it's cool
we're chilling
and rosie's like like getting uh can you
get me something to drink i don't want
anything to drink at all for some reason
i don't know why
there's no liquor when i went up there i
asked what do you have that's not a soda
shake lemonade like also i have i have
bottles under here if you want but
they're going to be like 350 oh i'm cool
thank you hennessy for 350 [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of here
and
i have the lemonade in my hand it's like
six dollars i'm like yo here's like 15
bucks just to be nice like i'm at the
strip club there's no liquor you
probably don't get tipped at all
here [ __ ]
and i call her [ __ ] for a reason
i now have the drink in my hand take
over
came back and sat down
sorry in my head i was doing i was
walking through yeah sorry i skipped my
my version of it sorry go so i'm back to
you go back to me
i drink the lemonade
she drinks a regular lemonade
okay
tastes a little weird but i just thought
it was like the tropicana one or
something you know from fountain
and then i don't remember anything
damn i don't think i ever heard about
this no no
no so i guess i can't really ask you
your side
you were fast
okay
i got this cup right here here's your
lemonade she's drinking it we're there
for it was fun 25 minutes maybe 20
minutes
and then she just starts feeling like oh
i feel sick like you throw up she i
think i'm gonna throw up
and then she just starts like
passing out i'm like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you i don't remember any of
that i just remember going like what the
[ __ ] is this i just remember waking up
the next morning and like a t-shirt or
something yeah what the [ __ ] is this
let's go i guess the [ __ ] i'm sorry we
start leaving i'm like yo you're not
even drunk what the [ __ ] wrong with
you at first i was like
we just got here oh rosie that's what i
thought it started becoming fun too it
was cool yeah because it was cool but i
was like rosie you're not even trying
all right did you drink before we left
because we did take shots where we left
yes we did so i was thinking she will
handle your liquor we took like two
shots
like damn it but as soon as i'm like
what the [ __ ] wrong with you this is
not normal and then she threw up like
what the [ __ ] and i she was like
those mexican dolls that are wood and
then you press the button on the bottom
they go
and they limp
you let go the button and they stand
back up that's what she was like
i get into the car and she's like
passing out in the sea like what the
[ __ ] and i'm thinking dude she's just
too [ __ ] drunk i can't believe a
couple shots got her
nothing i was i wasn't scared i was like
oh bro two shot okay
rosie two shots
i could drink and she could drink so i
was like oh he was a lightweight
[ __ ] but i wasn't okay and then
i wasn't even drunk at the strip club no
but i was thinking it was the shots i'm
like what else could it have been
i get her home and she starts throwing
up
and then i like have to watch her all
night so she'll throw up on her back and
[ __ ] so i'm up all night like oh come on
[ __ ]
and then i wake up and she wakes up like
i start talking and she don't remember
[ __ ] i go what do you mean you don't
remember [ __ ] nothing i think this [ __ ]
trying to roofie me
because i was she thought i was by
myself
like some dude the [ __ ] was she gonna do
if she roofied you take all my money in
my pockets i had gigantic back pockets
at the time
oh
and she was the nicest looking one there
like she looked like a wholesome like
student
she wasn't a stripper she was a [ __ ]
cashier bartender and i saw her go oh
she's yeah she probably get paid a lot
at all uh here nine dollar tip on a
lemonade [ __ ] that's why i called her
[ __ ] she tried to root thing is i
wonder
i did wonder because she went around and
got the drink i'm like
just put it from the [ __ ] thing all
right [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] just
give me the drink
i'm thinking
all of these things make sense now
that [ __ ] was trying to get me
didn't know i was with rosie
i didn't know the drink was for me yeah
damn you know what i'm saying
that's the only explanation she don't
remember [ __ ] she was throwing up and
falling down so when did you realize
that and when she was like i don't
remember anything but what do you mean
you don't remember anything
the next morning
i remember getting there hanging out for
a woman for a little bit and then i
drank the lemonade and then i don't
remember anything else yeah that's dude
the [ __ ] they were trying to get me
that's great that's horrifying the
people that weren't there nice yeah i'm
all nice and [ __ ] everybody was nice too
it was such a chill spot they didn't
know they were getting you but i'm
saying like
but just in general they're doing that
to people
no for real
but no there's a lot of people in there
there were
they they probably yo you're by yourself
dude you want to go to this private room
or something i'll wait till you pass the
arts problem
put them outside or something i don't
know i was like what the [ __ ] are you
kidding me dude
i'm nice you just saw me and go i'm
gonna get him
anybody can get caught because i was
super polite and i ain't like it's not
all that smart because it's like you
know who did it he was like
i couldn't believe it man i was shocked
thinking you were trying to get me [ __ ]
you i thought you were nice
oh
yeah so that happens i don't know why i
put what's your perspective
[ __ ] idiot
boom first time in vegas together strip
clubs oh whoa what happened
not with [ __ ] me and you only oh
that was so much fun
uh the first time for my birthday
i don't remember what day it was
was it my birthday i can't remember and
they didn't let us in
explain that
it was my birthday
weekend i think
and we went to vegas and i got this
really dope outfit
and they wouldn't let me in
damn that's your story [ __ ]
what else do you want me to say
we're in vegas right oh gosh here we go
here we go so we're in vegas roach gives
this outfit
somewhat revealing a little bit
revealing not crazy nothing insane
not i said no a little bit but nothing
crazy
walking up
it's my birthday birthday
we walk in and i'm starting to change in
all these [ __ ] hundreds
i i mean i remember the time i was like
dude i'm gonna spend this much money oh
my god and this is back before we ever
got paid for anything
anything for anything somebody spending
that much money
that hotel is so dope it was [ __ ]
awesome it was and then they upgraded us
and everything remember that yeah
it was awesome
and then
we get up there we start talking this
big [ __ ]
and i'm just i'm changing this money in
and the guy will i turn around
and the guy's like hey you can't come in
just like that to rosie i'm like hey why
paying for her to come in with me
it's like you can't wear that and here
you go
you can't those [ __ ] are naked sir
thank you
you're saying this is too much they're
[ __ ] naked
for money in there it was like a low v
cut and like low back and it was a dress
no those pants i mean it was this pant
suit but like it's it's like as a
revealing as a as a red show carpet
dress that girls wear like low cut it
wasn't crazy it was not crazy in a strip
club
into a strip club so we're watching i
thought it was perfect it was fun yeah
it was fine it was fine
right we're there he's like i'm like why
that's dumb that's too revealing man you
can't be in there man nah gotta change
she can change and leave or you can buy
this shirt
there's strip club shirts some strip
clubs should they have they had like a
[ __ ] xl or double xl and he goes it's
45 dollars
the shirt is 45 dollars
for the shirt
yeah i go you know what
we're going to go somewhere else man
thank you so much we're not going to
walk in can you give me my i don't want
the ones
and i was like you you're so st
you are really dumb that's how i felt so
cool this spot was bad
the story time about me going my first
strip club ever uh-huh
that's the same exact place i only knew
that place to go with her because like
i've been to one no we went to one we
went to it once before and then we tried
to go again for my birthday we went
there
because of
[ __ ]
and it was awesome [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
it was so much fun yeah it was cool [ __ ]
um
yeah so
and then they wouldn't let me in you
[ __ ]
you're a straight up og's friend
he has to explain it he might want you
to buy a shirt he said it was too
revealing he told us get the [ __ ] out he
did he was big
huge actually he was a big ass guy it
was so weird this dude told me he can't
come in
here what
i just remember telling him it's my
birthday
it was stupid it was stupid we've had a
lot of
we've had uh
portland oregon was a cool strip club
experience
it was cool portland's tight i liked it
it was weird that there's no taxes
how much to drink 15
but
here's the 20.
it's only 15
sick even at the strip club [ __ ] has tax
no taxes
but we went to that one strip club and
this one
the super pretty black chick with a
gigantic afro was like hey you guys
smell like weed do you want to go to
your hotel room right now
oh my god i looked at rosie like this
get her away
if she said that [ __ ] 25 minutes after
it would have been reasonable
she walked up to us my god you guys
smell like fire i will go to your hotel
you guys want to hang out right now i'll
get i'll i will leave you want your
hotel room i'm like oh hell no [ __ ]
yeah no thank you a little too look too
much
no thank you get the [ __ ] away from me
i'm chilling remember that [ __ ] i mean
we were in there for seconds not even we
barely sat down i mean we said we sat
that place was sick
it was next to the super nice indian
food spot that we found the guy was
super cool
didn't we eat somewhere first yeah
we got this indian spot where samosas
are as big as your head
they were bomb as [ __ ]
um but that strip club was wild as hell
portland was so much fun portland's
portland was fun
going to strip clubs with your
girlfriend is a lot more fun
she finds a friend every time
i would have lived in our building that
one time remember that's why once she's
like i have a boyfriend and he's from
merced shut the [ __ ] up
he's not my boyfriend i had a baby with
this dumb [ __ ] three years ago
i'm like he's from herself yeah he's
like yeah he's a dead he don't do [ __ ]
he [ __ ] tries to sell weevil
yeah
i [ __ ] hear you [ __ ] what's his name
oh i don't know him he's not from there
he lives there oh he's one of those
he's not from he's just he's on section
eight because it's easy to get
she was cool as she was really cool that
was here in l.a though yeah
uh no that was in vegas i'm burnt that
was in vegas what was it
it was
it was a vegas is that the cool spot
yeah
um
portland was awesome
portland was super fun
i don't remember at all it's like five
places and then we went to a [ __ ]
donut spot all drunk yep voodoo
doughnuts who do donuts
that's pretty much it
that went to upper playground
bought a bunch of [ __ ] and left that's
pretty much all me rosie do in places we
need to find more hobbies we don't do
stuff
you guys are like actual friends yeah we
don't do [ __ ] dude right now we just go
watch movies
you get high in the movie theater dude
oh my gosh did you tell mario what you
did last night
this is how i feel like there's an
inflatable tube named guys restaurant
nice actress
super bomb restaurant actually so my
thing okay everybody should talk [ __ ] to
og but i stop smoking in [ __ ] places
stop smoking joints he doesn't now
oh yeah
these are big hits yeah stiffer than his
fat joint in his hoodie pocket he's
smoking slowly yeah
like yo it's you you're smoking
your pocket you're on fire
stupid
so i've been ripping them
when the waiters aren't looking at any
restaurant and i've been ghosting it
until it's gone let not nothing but
sometimes i've been run out of breath
and i'll pull the old last time you got
lucky at that spot and you were sitting
playing power i sat under a vent i went
and it sucked the [ __ ] i ripped it
the whole time i was in the restaurant
nobody saw me no not one soul
so
not one
this
and i laugh at him and i feel like i'm
enabling it
but look this is my new thing
at restaurants because the hash pans get
me so [ __ ] violently high rip two at
a time because they don't burn out if
you hit them too hard at once they start
to burn it tastes a little burnt so if i
rip two
if i rip two it's like
a moderate hit on both but i'm getting
[ __ ] go i'm just [ __ ] up
um
so
at restaurants i've been waiting till
the waiter leaves and i'll go
at the movie theater all you got to do
is get a passive projector
and the last movie we watched with my
dad i failed about six times and i kept
looking at the screen
he's gonna [ __ ] up can't you just like
blow it down your shirt my little
sisters are not working for four seats
down i don't want to smoke next to him
somewhere you
blowing it like i got direction to it
but i do
i'm blowing that [ __ ] away it's [ __ ]
like nobody yeah
but i look up and i go oh my god it's
all over the [ __ ] projector you can
just see a clown
no this isn't even about last night's
story yeah i'm sorry but this is what
i've been doing lately because i've been
so [ __ ] high i haven't been smoking
weed at all i've just been smoking pens
the ashram pants topaz pens gummies i'm
getting [ __ ] up um
so really nice restaurants when the
waiter's not there
no i'll hit the depends but last night i
found the best cover of all
time are you ready
yes i'm gonna send you the clip she
tried to record me i just got the
aftermath i go like this
i'll hit two of them it'll hold it right
but i'll hit him hard as possible
so
last night they brought my phone
i was like oh sick and i ripped them so
violently hard right before she brought
that it went i ghosted a cloud and
brought him like oh that's a fat one and
i went like this
oh this is so hot like oh careful this
is steaming rosie look careful careful
because there's just a cloud coming from
our table and there's hell of people
around us nobody looked because they all
thought it was [ __ ] steam
oh it's hot it looks
you know like whenever you move your
pasta around
that's right i just went up and went
oh careful it's hot and no one you're an
artist
thank you
thank you i might as well have dunked on
our waitress
she didn't even she was cool as [ __ ]
she had rainbow uh pop rocket rocket
rocket colored hair
sick
um it's like a challenge now
oh my god
no it's not even that the fact that i
went it's steaming oh my god yeah
you worked it into
i [ __ ] turned red and got hot and
sweaty from laughing he just sat there
and left because he was like oh my god
this [ __ ] worked
and it was so good it was so well placed
everything
about it
yeah that was that's the worst that was
last night huh yes it was last night i'm
so tired that was last night
is there a possibility of putting our
writing questions i told you i'm
starting a running class i'm going to do
a running girl no she's been running the
[ __ ] marathon yeah literally
literally the [ __ ] marathon so she
has a running class and this running
class
it's only once once a month but rosie
got let in she didn't know she was
getting it they looked her instagram up
or something we're like oh yeah you're
allowed thank you oh so only people like
so she saw people she's been watching
with her we won't say we won't say any
more more [ __ ] people shut up
but there's this lady she [ __ ] loves
her soap operas and her mom and she was
in the class she was in there i had to
call myself and be cool when you walk in
just walk in they you don't touch
anything they bring you your weights
they bring you your water they bring
your towels hold on so it's a run class
so you run in intervals of like four to
eight minutes and then
every other time you do a workout with
weights or something like that and then
you run again right right run a track no
it's on crazy
are you ready
when you walk in each locker has a rolex
no it's a rolling one that they pulled
oh they've only oh
i thought it was for all of them no it's
not all the time it's the winders the
things that move
you take it off and put on the wire so
when your closet winds your watch i'm
going to take my watch to running
classes
that's some richness that's the most
bougie [ __ ] i've ever heard in my
[ __ ] life but they're my people that
class is only for socialite people
celebrities artists that's it
and when rosie went to her first class
they're like oh yeah and she got this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this you're
bringing me weights like oh this is the
once a month uh something something
class and that's when she realized like
oh [ __ ] everybody knew my name when i
walked in they looked up they they had
like researched rosie already oh [ __ ]
they even asked me do you prefer rosie
or daddy i was like what the [ __ ]
i ain't going to that cool that cool ass
class but i'm supposed to go to a new
class start in the morning but once you
start going you can get it i would love
to go on saturday
if it's possible i'm doing float tank on
saturday with rosie no [ __ ] sleep uh
slow tank deprivation yes we got dope
facials
i'm trying to uh not buy stuff and just
make my body better
that's why i got to find that chef i'm
getting it i'm getting it right in the
running class i'm going to think i'm
going to do the ufc gym too yeah
i'm trying to i'm trying to be like this
or i want to check out that [ __ ] over
yeah three acts you got three ah
it's okay i want to do like a pilates
class to get all like i want to do a
class for like yo eat this [ __ ] piece
of pizza you're gonna be buff after
you're gonna be so buff after get me
into bro for real god you know exercise
is fun if i could just make the [ __ ]
time for the [ __ ] like i have been
doing i'll do it but the running class i
would love to sleep in the morning it's
my first day
it was like the beginning of may i think
we could sleep in okay yeah
yeah
so i would love it okay my body won't
let me sleep in it's so [ __ ] annoying
i would love to just keep hitting i did
this morning i ripped the pens i went to
the bathroom i'm up i'm in the bathroom
ready up [ __ ] and i ripped it and i fell
asleep it was [ __ ] amazing oh yeah
when i wake up this one was under me
this morning under my body
um
yeah sorry
[ __ ]
running class
winning close rehearsal running classes
baller that's awesome i just ran six
miles today
[ __ ]
running so hard
i hate it but that's why i signed up for
it i figured
running class
what else are we doing
tomorrow
oh yeah so we just got a running class
how many edibles you're going to eat for
you go in the full tank
oh i didn't think about it
oh yeah float tank we're doing a float
tank yeah i have mushroom gummies
i have mushroom calves i have micro dose
caps nice i have like 10 left
and ate the mushrooms
we should do that first before you do
all that
what
do a float session first yeah before i
do mushrooms like normal try for i want
to see what it's like normally okay
because
you know me i know the second i stop
thinking and stop worrying about work
[ __ ] i will write a masterpiece
every every time i'm by myself dude i'm
like yo where was this at yesterday
i just need to not go oh i gotta answer
16 [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] all right i
gotta hit him he's waiting on this this
guy's waiting on this [ __ ] it feels like
my brain does this all day yeah you know
typewriter has been doing this and
they're on they're on track and he goes
that's me with everything and i'm like
oh i got halfway oh [ __ ] i'll come next
[ __ ] thing next [ __ ] that's
exactly how my brain works and i if i
could just stop
like today i was driving by myself which
is rare to my meeting
i was let's do it and i thought of an
entire music video and [ __ ] recorded
myself explaining the entire shot of a
shot
that was incredible
i have an idea i have a lot of good
music videos ideas i can't find the
right artist and i know exactly what
kind of artist this would happen
i'm just rambling here but that's what i
did today it's not often i drive by
myself because rosie's always with me so
i would love to shoot music videos i
just got to think of
i'll get it i'm doing a lot i'm we're
doing a lot of projects yeah we're doing
a lot of stuff
doing more just trying to do more things
thinking about season three
season three
oh also we cannot update yet but we got
a [ __ ] contract we've been
talking about today we we still need to
go over it we got that [ __ ] haven't
even opened it yet we need to go over
that [ __ ] today the contract and all the
[ __ ] we said shit's about to get crazy
wait on a contract
[ __ ] is here and now time for
revisions and or going i don't like that
or just go this is great
thank you we don't know yet
but yeah i forgot to tell you because i
haven't seen you but true yeah
that's going to be a big upgrade for the
show and our lives and our just level up
to get guests and sponsors and just push
forward with more [ __ ] overall
take this [ __ ] up to that next level
deal that's taken months to transpire
plenty of opportunities to rush it try
to do too much
but we played this chess game
masterfully
if i say so myself
and we're in perfect position right now
oh yeah yeah
very well we crashing
thank you guys so much for watching and
hanging out and always liking and
everything our highest paid month on
youtube let's go
sounds crazy we get actually paid from
youtube right from us never getting paid
we're getting paid from youtube on this
channel so thank you guys so much for
hanging out watching these ads because
it actually does help we actually win
money this month yeah
awesome best thing of all time
thank you guys very much um
yeah that was a light that was light
it looks like nothing crazy it's not
it's all nelly nelly in here
hi
it's so hot in here because last time it
was on 68 then it jumped to 74. it's
dumb hot in here probably what it just
did again some [ __ ] um
thank you
yeah you didn't seem all
anxious and [ __ ] she did not want to do
the last well she won't do the last
episode she was just nervous for it
yeah you're chilling now i'm fine it's
different next time we need a wheel we
need air pro we need something oh yeah
yeah we need to bear some [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i might get
yeah all right it's a different show
variety hour
newlyweds i make up questions for you
guys you make up questions for us losers
that's a [ __ ] bloody knuckles battle
okay okay
guys
um
thank you this is fun we're at an hour
and 41 minutes right now yes and thank
you for running all the behind the
scenes [ __ ] rosie you've leveled up
tremendously
with the show and with push trees and
the whole house yeah all the stuff that
you don't think you have to do
there's that's the main majority of it
that's the majority of the work honestly
the back end
setting up this setting this call up
sending that call it's crazy that's a
full-time [ __ ] job oh yeah
and it's the crucial part of the
business making sure the business
actually functions as a business yeah it
makes money yeah because like people
like us are good at this part of it
but there's just so it's so crucial that
like so many steps yeah all the
financials and everything are taken care
of
our names are on a card that says dope
as usual from bank of america which is
crazy
like does your card come in the mail yet
no oh man yeah yo i got mine
also the dopeziola is now
recognized by the government which is
awesome so i get paid as dopaziola
they gave me my debit card said
dopaziola spelled my real last name
the name you use
for years you're spelled wrong you know
the id that you have on file
[ __ ] the name of the whole
hotel
you spelled it wrong
it's okay that's all right
at least we got a card i swiped gas as
dope as you all the other days i was
doing i was doing a video and i bought
a liquor for the video that's coming out
tomorrow the oh new series high versus
drunk i got [ __ ] [ __ ] faced um
i bought that bottle as dope as yellow
money which was crazy
so cool thank you for getting that done
she got my dba done you got all this
[ __ ]
um also rosie very soon we a couple
years ago
started this thing rosie started the cbd
company
just got it in the works and all the
plans now it's finally coming uh-huh
oh it's fine yeah it's not just a cvd
company let me get a gummy no can't
really talk about it yet but i don't
want to put too much completely
different but soon [ __ ]
cool as [ __ ] epic hopefully by yo target
pick this up don't be a [ __ ]
home goods
home good think about this though
and if you don't have a coffee table the
book turns into a coffee table
honestly i don't care if i'm 85 years
old
seinfeld is going to make me laugh for
the rest of them oh my god i laugh all
the time and watch it every night and it
makes me sadder as the years go by
knowing that they're not that age
that's when cameras were really good
just started getting really good so
seinfeld jerry sniffle to me is 35. yeah
but and i see him now you're 70.
oh my god that means i'm older now you
know what i mean no no like when you
talk about an uh
wedding singer she's like when you're
always like when i'm old i'm probably
gonna look like buddy hackett
and that was when he was what 30
and that was 25 20 years ago he's about
55 right now
he's about 15 years away from talking
about that time
and when i was watching that who would
have known that 45 years would go by
real quick
that's what scares me
i don't like that watching these shows
over and over makes me forget that time
is gone and when i get out of it i go
oh yeah i'm not a little kid
[ __ ] me time went by real [ __ ] fast
[ __ ] me up it's like watching click
adam sandler promoting everything you do
out here man i'm just nothing nothing
but [ __ ] show
come on
peter
help me
dante help me
i'm gonna send him this clip but yo your
friends with adam sandler just let him
come on the [ __ ] show
he's gonna go hey brother
oh hi yo dante in real life is dante in
the movies oh my gosh dante in real life
is the same [ __ ] uh
grand uh uh that's my boy donny burger
a well put together donnie burger is
peter dante real life the funniest fun
[ __ ] in the room oh you you know
like oh man
he's a
i love that guy never lose that help me
get your friend on the show my favorite
person ever it's okay the first person
to ever give me an acting lesson
was peter dante from all the adam
sandler movies
i smoked too much weed and i was about
to throw up i was doing this video with
him it was supposed to be 30 minutes
turned four and a half hours because we
just kept going the director's like
let's do more and we just kept doing it
i sat on a stack of books this big i
remember i was there dude
it was like it was like a story time
looking set uh-huh and he was reading
weed wraps reviews as
so like a santa claus style and i would
go
and mark from something something
and uh
i'm i'm like yo can i use the restroom i
only wanted to do that so i can go throw
water in my face and maybe drink water
from the faucet and try to throw up
because i was gonna throw up i smoked a
half zip to my [ __ ] face didn't eat
because i knew i was filming i i need to
stop doing that yeah you do i was
supposed to be 30 minutes during the
four and a half hours we thought we were
going to be
done yeah i'd go in the bathroom i
haven't used this bathroom i'm like oh
my god i'm going to throw up and go
throw up i don't want to know him throw
up and dante's like i'll go with you
so we go into the bathroom like yo get
away from me get away from me i need to
like silently puke i go into the urinal
i unzip my pants just to make it look
like i'm about to pee and i start going
and i'm trying to throw up in the urinal
oh so he does it like
this [ __ ] guy on the internet smokes
a bunch of we can't handle the weed but
i smoked a half zip and we were filming
i was trying to power smoke it for like
the film for smoke and i didn't eat and
i was just like getting like
people pass out
i was pale by the end of it
and i'm in the bathroom like that
and i'm trying to throw up
in the urinal without him knowing i
can't believe it and he comes out and go
oh yeah i'm done all right flush
i'm still vomiting puke and then he goes
i thought i was gonna [ __ ] throw up
in there right now i go oh dude me too i
almost [ __ ] threw up in the euro i
just let it go from there and then he
started like giving me acting lessons
on what i should be doing and then he's
like well
you're fine
try something like this
i was like you saw the first person ever
gave me an active lesson was uh and he
oh
that's bugging me you'll remember i'll
remember it and i'll bring it up next
week
why did we talk about this oh adam
sandler adam sandler dude there's
stories for days i have stories for
[ __ ] years
um but that was such a fun time i have
that picture we'll pop it up on here i
have it somewhere sitting on a stack of
books
oh yeah thank you i have a picture yet
somewhere out there someone's got that
footage someone the full four hours of
me and dante going back and forth for
four hours i never got any of it five
years ago damn yeah
very fun fun moment
um
rambler yep rambly
uh rosie yeah i just told the whole
story for nothing red teddy [ __ ]
oh red city i'm like red titty
oh yeah last i gotcha rant city dude i i
got all hot and hashed out now i'm just
like
[ __ ] just keep going
here you go again
what
up
thank you for coming on the show
appreciate it
welcome are you guys going to have like
a normal wedding would you say
or is it going to be like i want blank
check first party the first time he was
like i got the million dollars as
macintosh
that's what i wanted to be like okay
because i could see it going either way
yeah i kind of want to
go over the top i was kidding i don't
give a [ __ ] okay whatever you want i was
gonna say i could see you guys being
like super minimalist like next to
nothing or
i could go either way sick over the top
i don't know decorations i don't know
fun stuff i don't have any hobbies but
getting [ __ ] high and working yeah so
i don't have ideas oh you mean you're
not a professional [ __ ] wedding
planner i couldn't even tell you more
than what like a photo booth and a horse
donkey from [ __ ] mrs doubtfire what
the [ __ ] else do i have a whole design
to it you gotta i didn't i don't know
how to do that yeah yeah
whatever you want will do
pretty much
yeah exactly yeah that'll be cool
all the security guards that we have
because i'm gonna have security guards
oh yeah we have to uh be painted all
green like the army plastic soldiers
and they stand at the door and move fine
with me
oh [ __ ]
adult money
oh i'll give you more money paint your
face
paint
hey what's up [ __ ]
that's all he's gonna say
you know i had an idea to meet rosie
doing a re-enactment and oh it mean you
we talked about it and og plays every
character
he plays every other character but
the judge the cop the this the the
lawyer
[ __ ] telling me dude or not
yeah this turned into two hours instead
of one at 1 30 i was like we're done
that's all right we usually shoot about
an hour and a half past what we're
aiming for no but i'm gonna i'm gonna
wrap it up yeah we got it we gotta wrap
it up guys but you don't know but it's
like
10 o'clock thursday night
yeah tuesday we gotta edit so we're
trying to keep it short and i just
started talking about random [ __ ] again
do it often
wrap it up b
anything else you want to add marty
baller ass way
man go ducks
oh my gosh
why do you say
hometown
because they're anaheim this is orange
county's team oh my god the whole time i
kept going the mighty ducks on the east
coast yeah no cam's team cam's growing
up with the ducks being his team that's
cause the colorway is ball yeah that's
that's why i got it yeah the color is
stupid tight yeah go to a game
have you been together yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know you should go again
i really i know i i'm
i need to start doing more [ __ ] like
that i know we don't do [ __ ]
i don't do [ __ ]
ever went to dinner last night cause i
didn't have to do anything i went
all right all right i could do stuff
that's my real goal and we get more time
back is to like do cool oh man i can't
wait to get a [ __ ] hobby
oh it's gonna be cool actually i don't
even want a hobby i'd just rather start
another business or something you're
gonna turn into a [ __ ] david goggins
style marathon sprinter because i could
just do like that's probably gonna do a
different type of workout for sure
yeah you know like when i didn't have
weed i had no friends when i moved to
oregon all i did was get [ __ ]
insanely in shape
because i'm like what else am i gonna do
i feel like if i can make more time to
work out and hang out with you
[ __ ] i told you when we were what
like 22 we first started dating like all
you gotta do is
you do whatever you want all day
help me with the house
i'll find a way to make a bunch of
[ __ ] money doing something sick as
[ __ ]
and then you just like
go to the gym because that's what you do
anyway yeah don't give a [ __ ]
that's what we said we first started
doing my home
i'll make money some
tight-ass way and we do remember that
[ __ ]
saying that [ __ ] is crazy to say it
again that's crazy because i think about
it all the time it's a [ __ ] trip man
because today i did nothing
it was amazing
i mean i just did laundry and clean the
house but that's still nothing you need
your trainer and [ __ ] but
you weren't on the phone with quickbooks
for five hours
migrating e-commerce i didn't have to
talk to ship station i didn't do none of
that
it was awesome yeah chilling today oh
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] odd it is weird
sometimes it's weird i can't remember
the last time i did that
i'd like to do more of it
i have some i don't thank you
i don't have a lot of money i have a
little i keep it in a jar on top of the
refrigerator in my sister's basement i
would like to put more in that jar
that's where you come in adam sandler
just come to the show
i'm so happy it makes up for everyone's
questions
i knew it okay i redeemed myself that's
fine we're good he took his hand you got
to get out of here
we gotta get out of here
um
thank you
go ducks he says go ducks go ducks that
would be a ball or ass if that had a
push trees logo in the middle i'm going
to [ __ ] my pants yeah
i kind of like that look when does it
start again
when does hockey season start
you know who gives a [ __ ] i'd rock that
right now yeah i don't know what the
[ __ ] season it is
oh the [ __ ] season it is
you're good dad marty you're a good dad
damn likes this [ __ ] i rock this [ __ ] it
matches the exact orange on the [ __ ]
set
done dead on all right thank you thank
you for being here rosie's instagram
stoner underscore dottie d-o-t-t-i
rosie's youtube don't matter cause she
don't wanna [ __ ] post on the [ __ ] no
what's your snapchat
stoner daddy no underscore yep stoner
dottie all one word d-o-t-t-i-e
twitter same as snapchat
no underscore so is the only thing i'm
underscoring oh [ __ ]
huh
how did you think about that no uh-uh
yeah
no one just going on twitter either
she's not
refreshing accounts every week
she's nice
she's nice and just makes content no
they just shadow banned me
yeah that's about it yeah when rosie
posts me they delete her uh story it
violates community guidelines when she
posts me it's [ __ ]
insane also quick update i did talk to
the instagram people i told you about
earlier they said someone is actively
paying to take my account down
so that's fine they said yes for sure
but i can't find out who
because it's like a v it's like
basically he's like try to find somebody
in a vpn scrambler like it's the same
process it's just a ghost doing it
so somebody's spending money all right
somebody out there and that narrows it
down to a few people like who's got
money
eight bands to erase me
all the time what if it's somebody out
there that doesn't have any money and
that's why it takes a couple months to
get taken down because they're working a
regular job
just saving
just to delete me
panhandling they're working two jobs
what are you saying for them i don't
[ __ ] with this [ __ ] online just
don't look at his page
nah yeah but i'm gonna set to do so he
might as might as well pretty much
another [ __ ] says something is
getting shot hate hate hate hate hate
iced tea
haters ball yeah you gotta get out of
here yeah yeah i got here it's 157. at
141 until this guy here
now that we got like i'm gonna call that
a chapel's reference too yeah we gotta
get one out we gotta get one out all
right we're good now yeah yeah you won
all right there's the [ __ ] iced tea
we we done we're done thank you for
being here that's all your socials thank
you for being here the last 25 minutes
was essentially
just a facetime conversation that we
have at the house yeah we're just
missing april yeah he's missing april
going he's a [ __ ] no no no that's not
what happened what happened that's
awesome
rosie listen to me no is she there is
rosie there
that's pretty much our facetime
conversation and then every coming in
and going
yeah after five seconds going
and he just slowly pops in
shows yeah
yeah
i love these oh man okay all right all
right we're done we gotta get out of
here two hours we did two hours didn't
feel like two hours at all i gotta stop
smoking the og
i gotta start me too i gotta start
mixing the weeds yeah because this og
made me feel down at the beginning and
now this hash even though it's gmo yeah
you feel a little up
i kind of feel that it's so odd and sad
but we figured it out last week right
yes but like i'm about to try to not be
fat anymore and not smoke oh geez people
are gonna be like you changed
[ __ ] you did you have fat in the
morning you like to smoke hybrids
[ __ ] you
and go oh
that's pretty much it
also
just to think just to throw it out there
yeah these mics
do look like a thrifty's ice cream cone
they make it square okay okay guys
throwing out there
that's you know what i'm saying
on your mind
every episode actually i'm sure every
[ __ ] episode when i'm talking the
guests go that looks just like a thrifty
[ __ ] ice cream cone
i thought that i didn't like the square
ones you know what i'm saying when they
come like a shooter
thinking i want yogurt but they never
have bomb flavors in the thing it's like
the bible crazy whole pack crazy [ __ ]
okay yeah sorry we have to get out of
here because now i'm probably green
and
bring back push pops
bring back a [ __ ] dinosaur
flintstones push pop they do have
yeah at the [ __ ] liquor stores okay
we're going like grandma get some change
basically
i'm
that's impossible
one day we're gonna have to say
watch your memories on screen like oh my
god just
somebody pay me to watch the [ __ ] i'm
talking about i was right
same [ __ ] stream
oh gosh you know what take it back i
don't want to do that that's creepy
we'll take it back we're at all right
ready we're at an hour 59 minutes and 52
seconds we're gonna get out of here in
exactly two hours we almost went into
another tangent about replaying people's
memories on the screen that could you
know about another thirty five forty
that would have [ __ ] been all up
like doctor strange we just watched
like that
hurry up scotty all right guys
thank you guys
appreciate it city
rant
[ __ ] city i'm sorry
hey don't we coughing start this whole
episode over here
caught one cop we start over from the
top from the top
roll it
all right guys thank you
i got a quick horrible story about that
real quick oh gosh go but what
i'm interested all right the chat's
going crazy going oh yeah
the game was over marty [ __ ] brought
it back all right go
all right full eight mile i'm doing my
first ever showcase at this little bar
called broadway joe's and buffalo
all right me and my homeboy get up there
on the stage and we got the song that we
had did together i bought the beat he i
did the first verse on the hook he had
like the second i had the second verse
the other third verse some [ __ ] like
that so we're in this janky ass set up
in this bar it's full you know just full
of random people and [ __ ] i go up there
i don't know how to use my voice on a
mic yet so i'm like
straining my voice right away off the
bat and i can't really hear myself in
the mic either over the music so i'm
straining my voice i've never really
performed live before
so i'm like losing my voice
about through the first hook you know
verse hook
so going into the second verse and my
voice is like gone
it's it's on its way out
and now the i can't really hear myself
in the mic the music's too loud
my height man next to me my boy i've
talked about a bunch on this show he's
like
hold on hold on [ __ ] that hold on stop
the music stop
bring that [ __ ] back it fixly starts
coming after the sound man fix the
[ __ ] levels bring that [ __ ] back
so now he starts the song from the
[ __ ] top and now i got no voice
so now i gotta run back through my whole
song again with no voice to get to his
third verse to end this [ __ ] song
yeah so so
were you able to speak
no i literally that second passed
through it was like what did you do
though raspy st no i kept going oh yeah
we got through it the killer sounded
like dog [ __ ]
was like
that sounds great you ever really lose
your voice though it's just not there
yeah it's weird it'll go quick on you
it's weird it'll go quick
concerts yeah
and lots of joints i've lost my voice on
joints and cannabis cups
i had joints and talk to people like
like takes my like scratched my [ __ ] up
so remember there's been times when i
lose my voice completely after canon
sketch because trying to talk over the
music yeah
yeah everybody to everyone
there we go yeah that was embarrassing
that was
yeah my first time ever out there
embarrassing
embarrassing
yeah picture he's going through puberty
yeah his voice is crazy the whole time
clean through the whole song i imagine
having to double back through your own
song just to begin with with your voice
that's a little bit extra like all right
i just went you know with your voice
it's bad he says
unable to speak he's terrible for music
yeah oh my gosh yeah guys so
thank you all right it's okay
all right well
that was everything man i think we're
gonna get out of here we got all right
two hours
not bad it was a chill episode
nothing crazy it was pretty sick i don't
remember most
i don't remember i almost
when i watch these on monday is the
first time watching it i don't remember
[ __ ] fresh new episode it's crazy dude i
mean the chat dying
no we said that [ __ ]
that's why the solos is most fun
[Music]
and i can say whatever i want no one's
here to like hey i know you just met me
also let me talk about this 51st date
situation
repetitively
oh my god let me reference 16 things you
might not know
uh
it's okay yeah okay you ready mm-hmm
i'm done
i'm out
all my questions are done thank you for
being here we're running over
we already went over your socials and
how to find your stuff
marty before we get out of here
everybody go follow the dopest
usual pot the dope as usual podcast it's
on instagram as dope as usual podcast
sorry we have so many emails we need to
button these up a little bit i have so
many emails and three companies with the
word dope yeah so it's like something
dope as usual podcast on instagram just
hit 75k yes very cool thanks guys
appreciate that pretty [ __ ] cool
twitter same exact thing correct
as usual podcast we popped him up last
time and our tick tock is the same thing
i believe
um part of this new deal is going to be
a lot more social media content
a lot all right people are going to be
helping us and we're going to get this
[ __ ]
popping because i don't know seo
searches i don't know how to make
facebook videos pop i will make the
videos and that's it
it's all you need to all i know how to
do i don't know how to do all the other
seo [ __ ]
here we go here we go but yeah go follow
the dope as usual
stuff follow our social media big shout
out to whoever the [ __ ] won these
magical prizes behind us they're in
frame yeah
on youtube the dopest shop that's a
youtube channel for our company
dopashop.com
we just started our sweepstakes we just
started our [ __ ] we're getting our and i
didn't tell you our nft shit's about to
go i know it's nfts i know our nfts are
basically just a membership ticket
yeah
i mean the arts yes it's gonna you can
do your thing with it
getting our nft is
gonna be pretty ridiculous yeah and
i'll tell you more about it i don't want
to give it away yet but
it's not just hey i bought one and i
have it in my wallet it's like hey by
the way something tangible
i can go where i won what it's attached
to physical cool [ __ ]
yeah anyway this is kind of just the
start this is not for enough this is
just for the yeah yeah say thank you
well yeah we got the new halo xbox and
ps5 we're just giving people tomorrow
yeah tomorrow on uh live on youtube
we're gonna give it away um yeah and the
forbes articles coming out this month
[ __ ] it's about to be sick
um but yeah that's where you can find
everything we do pushtrees.com
thedopashshop.com
dopaziola.com thoseusualpodcast.com
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i get to leave a lot so i'm not
gonna even say socials so i don't even
know what they are
um yeah just go to the website all right
find it find our stuff yeah we make you
look for it a little bit you got to
really want to find that yeah you got to
want to you got to want to know what
this is where this free content is oh
gosh
[ __ ] search for it
all right let's get out of here before
we keep going thank you so much for
being here appreciate you
thank you
thank you guys
thanks marty thanks babe um oh i'm high
we still gonna do ad read too
all right
all right thank you guys so much for
being here from marty rosie and i this
has been another episode of the dope as
usual podcast have a dope ass day
thank you
every day we do this you look like that
picture of lisa simpson
that's how i feel like actually
[Music]
uh
how you living well how you feeling well
how you living in living
[Music]
hi
hi
i'm really high
i'm high as [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] eyes out
[Music]